welcome to the GSB within an entourage a
panel like to be very interactive today
so we'll definitely reserve lots of time
for Q&A I'll introduce the speakers and
then I'll give them a series of
questions probably the same set of
questions and we'll have them go through
it and then we'll open it up for
questions and I thought I might offer a
few of my own insights from the VC
perspective and from the past chairwoman
formal members it's my perspective so
let me start at the end gina gina
bianchini forgot the right is a GSB 2000
she founded hermana communications of a
writer of hosted marketing intelligence
software to companies and their
advertising agencies in march of 2000
well in her second year of business
school they are backed by sequoia
capital and dentsu one of the world's
largest advertising agencies and she
currently serves as harmonics chief
marketing officer prior to founding
harmonic gina worked at McKinsey &
Company cks group and Goldman Sachs hope
I got that all right then we have
Melissa Parsons who is a GSB 78 and also
has an engineering degree from Stanford
she's the founder of reach fitness club
which offers Pilates aerobics and dance
lessons they also do management
contracts for corporations such as
Oracle she founded the nonprofit
organization meeting for good scene
was helping the community and she's
worked as a management consultant at BCG
and Bain and worked at bechtel as an
engineer and we have Marsha out who
isn't a Stanford MBA the Harvard MBA was
the co-founder of Eve com which launched
in june nineteen ninety nine as the
first website talk for beauty products
on the web ecomme was sold in may two
thousand she's currently president of
category management at kean the leading
person-to-person marketplace for wild
rice and before founding ecomme marsh or
to mckinsey & company and as a financial
analyst at worcester team wasserstein
perella and then we had Betty purlin who
was GSB class of 83 founder of personal
shopping calm a personalized shopping
service on the web and previously she
co-founded a women's apparel company New
York called Eleanor p Brenner and worked
at senior levels in several startups in
addition she was general manager room
books which developed children software
and she's currently working on several
consulting projects hopefully I got all
your chores right so I thought I'd just
say a few words and then I'll launch
into questions for the panel I try to
think about what are the elements of
success in entrepreneurial venture and I
want the panel is to sort of address the
personal side of it so I just kind of
compile the list of what we look for is
it's changed a little bit over time I
started adventure in 93 coming out of
the recession you know went through the
bubble and you know now we're sort of
back to maybe that 98 timeframe in terms
of taste and size of deals and types of
businesses were funding I think number
one for us is the experience vision and
energy of the team but it isn't just you
know that the original vision is going
to be the one that's you know executed
on it's the flexibility the perseverance
is a team that's you know going to make
it happen no matter what also hasn't
thrown their way and often you see grips
of entrepreneurs that have worked
together before and so they've had a
bonding experience whether they've spun
out of a big company or the second start
up together or they went to business
school together I mean sometimes it's
that helps the team bond it's also the
strong triumvirate between CEO board and
management team so you know three strong
components not you know super amazing
CEOs very controlling and does
everything and has a weak team
underneath him or her but someone who
really hires strong people and looks for
a board they're going to be you is you
know a set of individual to collaborate
and communicate with on just sort of
manager at the moment so when you see
that kind of functional triumvirate
company a lot better shot potentially
large and rapidly growing markets this
is the hard one because I remember our
HK predicted certain optical employment
markets would be 20 billion or you know
actually the summit was to be 20 billion
that somewhere as largest 325 billions
back from 99 and some of those same
market segments are projected to be 3
million this year you know so clearly
you know no one has you know the kind of
knowledge of market timing and you know
economic cycles it makes it tough but
y'all at least believe that this is
going to be a large emerging market we
like to find something that could grow
to a billion dollar market over a couple
years and that prod means arson trench
competitors already attacking it with
some kind of solution so next point
would be strong and extensible
competitive advantage you know ideally
see some kind of invention but sometimes
it's more than architectural advantage
or bringing together you know different
forms of IP so you know we often say
well that's an execution play but there
ought to be something that gives the
company a competitive advantage probably
some number of months a clear and
compelling business model so the correct
form of the solution service product
there's no one answer appropriate
channels pricing that makes sense you
know just that's probably the area we
work the most women committed company
even if they come up with the right
business model reasonable capital
requirements you know we might have
funded something during the bubble that
took 23 even a billion dollars to get to
break even which I can't believe we
actually did that but money was sort of
infinite then I would say today it takes
over 50 million is going to get pretty
hard scrutiny we probably wouldn't fund
it and then I think I already talked
about luck timing and connections you
know I used to think when I was sitting
in your position that I was going to be
an entrepreneur to have to have the
brilliant idea and they didn't think I
would I actually think it's more about
where you are in time and where you are
you know relative to an opportunity so
for example you might be in a big
company but you're exposed to a problem
you're exposed to other individuals and
you find yourself in a position to solve
that problem and I've even seen
entrepreneur's come in our door with
absolutely no idea great collection of
folks they go out and interview 20
customers in an area where they have
domain knowledge and they come up with
coalition you know so it's purely a
choice to be an entrepreneur not you
know the idea that drove it so let me
come back to the panel now and maybe
we'll just go down the line so we'll
start on this end if you could each tell
us your your entrepreneurial story you
know what did you plan to be an
entrepreneur was there a particular
person or event that inspired you well I
was I was recruited to be an
entrepreneur in my first venture a
fashion designer in New York was looking
for a partner to Solomon's apparel
company and through mutual friends we
got hooked up I really didn't see myself
as an entrepreneur that was my first job
out of business school but it actually
was a great way to become an
entrepreneur it was great in this
situation chemical partner this was
somebody that actually had industry
experience and knowledge and together we
work very hard and make a successful
venture and it was a situation where I
didn't have the idea was somebody else's
idea and somebody else's vision years
later when i started personal shopping
calm that was a situation where I had a
vision I had a vision of what the
potential of the internet could be with
respect to e commerce and I actually had
this vision very early on before there
was ecommerce I got the URL for the
company years before there was any
e-commerce that existed
and I sat on it and I started to work on
the concept when things were just
beginning to roll so for me it was great
to get into entrepreneurship the way I
did kind of not something I set out to
do but something I fell into learned a
lot from work very hard for six years
had a successful venture and then I
could go off on my own when I did have
an idea I did have a passion for
something um I definitely never thought
I was going to be an entrepreneur I was
at McKinsey i went to HBS and then i
went to work at McKinsey for I was there
for about three years and I actually
thought I was going to just stay at
McKinsey become a partner and you know
live happily ever after but after about
three years I had been traveling
straight for three years I had never had
a week in town in my in New York where I
was living and I really got tired of it
and so I started to think about what
else i would want to do and it was about
summer of 98 actually when all this
happened and a good friend of mine who
was actually here at Stanford at the
time and who actually came to Stanford
we had been roommates right out of this
out of undergrad when we were both
analysts in different investment banks
and we have still we were still friends
and she had come to Stanford
specifically with the idea of starting a
business of starting a company and so
she approached me to start a company
with her but it was income of the
enterprise software space and I had been
doing actually a lot of work at McKinsey
in e-commerce we had been interviewing a
lot of different consumer companies like
barnes and noble clinique avon all types
of companies like that and I
just thought it was I thought that was
that was my most exciting work that I
was doing at mckinsey the stuff I was
doing on the side so I thought that you
know there's something wrong here so I
decided I told my friend that I would
love to start a business with her but I
wanted to do something that I was really
interested in because frankly if if it
didn't work out at least I wanted to
have a great experience something I was
really passionate about I just couldn't
see myself doing enterprise software you
know in the long term if it didn't work
out as a start-up so we started ecomme
together and kind of went through the
whole cycle we were able to raise
funding really pretty quickly given the
high the timing that it was and I moved
out here to California he started the
business together and it was a great
experience for me because one My partner
and I her name is Miriam the feces she
was GSP I think 98 we were great I think
a great team together we had a implicit
level of trust because we had lived
together before we had I think very
similar values and I think that's really
really important when you're starting a
company and if you're going to have a
partner the other thing I would say is I
think it's really important to have a
partner and it was a great way for me to
get involved in an entrepreneurial
environment this was really something I
was passionate about so I felt like I
could really put everything behind it
and then when we sold the company in
may of 2000 we you know we were at the
time about I don't know 150 people we
had gone through the whole cycle of
launching a website we are doing we had
to run rate of about 10 million dollars
in revenue and you know so I got kind of
the full experience of what it was like
to start something take it from the two
of us to a rule you know what I would
think was a relatively large
organization and then after that you
know I've gone back and I'm actually no
longer at kean i worked at another
internet company for about a year after
i finished up with Eve and and it was
actually more as an employee I was VP of
category management has joe said and
then but i actually have left there and
I've started a smaller company called so
well which is a luxury jewelry company
and its really interesting because my
idea for this company actually also came
out of my experience that Eve where I we
did a lot of research to expand into new
markets so I would say that you can
actually get a lot of your ideas from
your environments that you work in which
is kind of similar to what of you are
saying and it's really interesting to
have gone back for me into the corporate
environment after having done a start-up
and I think I can now really more
objectively say where the benefits and
you know advantages as well as
disadvantages to both the
entrepreneurial side as well as the
corporate side right okay now I think
that my store is service similar in some
ways and a little different in others
and that my path was really both
personal need and fulfillment i started
off believe in I'm the ancient one here
when I was at Stanford I was the only
woman engineer and went to bechtel was
the first woman hired as a full
there had 30,000 engineers so it's a
little bit connected boston consulting
group there was one other woman who was
promised and then was one of the group
that broke off to form Bain & Company I
think that women were not quite as well
accepted them as they are now and
entrepreneurialship I mean there really
was a glass ceiling that was pretty
strong at the time I started reach it
was for a personal need and that was I
was in poor health and was looking for a
place to get in shape to start my
high-tech big business and then I had I
had my little boy and found that that
was more important anything come across
my desk in a long time I think a lot of
people can relate to that and wanted to
find it something that would give me the
balance in life and at the same time my
husband got very ill and actually passed
away and i found that oh i am the only
breadwinner and the only parent and they
only i did not have partners the only
one responsible for this small business
and it has it has been a great vehicle
for me to give me the balance in life
the financial independence I can now
retire I didn't make it till I was
speech for I'm out 55 but the idea if
you can do it when you're 40 when you're
in business school just seems you know
so doable but I've now achieved that
I think that a small business and the
fact that it is something as low tech as
a health club just tells you that you
don't have to have the perfect idea you
just have to use the skills I used a lot
of the consulting skills and learn how
to position the business you use the
skills you pick up along the way and
you're just stubborn enough that you
don't understand that you can't do it
just doesn't crush your mind so that's a
nice story no sure I have a quick
question first is is anybody in the room
started business and or planning on
starting a business anybody sort of
following school okay okay just just
checking so she's down yeah yeah you
should probably get a little bit higher
in two thousand when I was in business
school which I think we're the class
that you know you guys have gotten
yelled that about and from the job
recruiting perspective ya heard that
that's nice um sorry sorry about that my
experience is a entrepreneur I didn't
necessarily know what I wanted to do out
of business school and in my second year
of business school my former boss from
the company that I worked at before
school came to me and said you know
marketing is only getting more complex
the number of media channels and
customer segments and creative messages
that a marketer has to manage on a daily
basis has just gotten you know
ridiculous let's go start a company and
so in my second year at business school
I you know it's been basically the
morning going to class in the afternoon
going up to Sand Hill Road and a venture
capital firm up there that essentially
incubated me and the company that that I
found it so you know it just seemed at
that moment you know why not and you
know I think kind of coming out of
business wool it was you know I had
nothing to lose and I
don't feel that way three years later
now that being said I think you have to
be absolutely insane at times to
continue to move forward with the
company and an idea when a lot of people
especially rational people tell you you
know no you can't do it or it's it's a
scary time or whatever and yet I am
definitely here to tell you that passion
and emotional commitment to an idea and
a company combined with utterly rational
decision-making when and where you can
you know he's a recipe for success in
2003 is it was in 1998 and was in 1993
and I'm also really excited because i
love you calm that was like such a great
site are you guys out is if still in no
unfortunately the new footage that got
us they shut us down about six months
but your answer like a total celebrity
you're in all the fashion magazines with
the with the little I'm your new line
I've seen it like oh my god I like I'm
all like they're strapped in here yeah
so anyways that's that's that's my story
you know you guys have had a theme here
of once you go entrepreneurial you
probably don't go back and it also
confirms my belief that it's as much
genetic i would say environmental more
so you know it almost feels like a set
of personnel
talked about a lot of them tenacity you
know maybe desire for control and
flexibility so aside from that the right
place right time you know to almost
BYU's what to do based on who you are
you not to be curious that what you guys
think it takes to be successful I'm in a
lot of folks you know especially in the
class of two thousand or before raise
their hands that I'm in being
entrepreneurial might find a hairdresser
was yeah angel funding you know GSP
seriously yeah while expending my hair a
task me and I tell me more about dsl and
my land my landlord actually my landlord
started a company called rent calm and
it's like you know it was the aggregator
of rental properties in palo alto and
beyond so I mean it was crazy i think
everybody raised their hand because it
felt like you don't be left behind or
you know the it looks like instant
wealth creation etc but now that the
samson settled I think it's back to
those who feel it calling or willing to
take risk are probably willing to make
some sacrifices but I would love to hear
you guys have gone through pre bubble
bubble beyond you know what were the key
factors in your success well you know
the first thing I think is important is
to have a passion for what you're doing
I think that's very important for you
and for the entire company I think you
need the company needs a good idea and
good execution of that idea which means
you need to have
team and I found the very early stages
of getting something off the ground that
you need to do a lot of networking and
have good connections that's very
helpful that helped me tremendously when
I was working on personal shopping calm
just started talking to people who led
me to other people into some
entrepreneurial coaches who let me to be
seized and lawyers and because the dude
is doing that work a big part of it yes
actually so for me that way to me yeah
yeah but that's one of the biggest
assets you all walk out of here with and
that lasts a lifetime how much your
garden um I'd say the biggest thing is
perseverance I mean I can't even tell
you it's like you know one day you think
you're going to be a gazillion error and
that you're going to build this huge big
business and then the next day you think
you're going out of business and it's
like that dramatic and so I think that
perseverance is so so important and in
kind of being able to have the
personality to deal with sort of those
ups and downs and I think in order to do
that that's really why I mean people say
passion but i think it's the passion
that lets get you through sort of those
highs and lows because it's really an
incredible roller coaster and it's
incredibly satisfying when you you know
so can achieve the smallest results but
it's also incredibly heartbreaking when
you know a client or an account you've
worked hard for decides for some reason
kind of beyond your control that you're
not they're not going to work with you
anymore and I think what I've definitely
seen Xena sort of starting another
venture is that it's two steps forward
one step back it really isn't you know
in the sort of the flurry of the ball
era it was
like it felt like it was just like this
because everything was moving so fast
but in reality it's it's kind of like a
little bit zigzag so I think
perseverance is really really important
and I think in order to also help you
with those ups and downs that's really
why it's great to have a partner or a
great team around you he is equally
passionate about what you're doing
because you know sometimes it's you need
to be able to rely on other people
because you won't always have that you
know one hundred and twenty-five percent
belief that you can make this thing
happen I equate it to thee to the you
know that in high school there was
always that couple that like they loved
each other one moment and then they like
hated each other and fought like the
next moment and it could be that kind of
emotional swing like throughout the day
and you just like looked at them you're
like how could you possibly stay in this
relationship you know if it's going up
and down I think the same thing is like
starting a company because the the highs
and lows that you can feel on a daily
basis at times more amplified are just
absolutely amplified and and yet it's
rewarding to after yeah well I know the
other time so the only other thing I
would says I do think that network is
important but I think basically not
being shy is really really important you
know for a lot of things that we were
doing HBS or Stanford or McKenzie net
worth just didn't matter because we were
talking to beauty companies and you know
most people most of the beauty companies
aren't run by such sophisticated and
management
that's the honest got no commentary
there it's the truth but it meant we had
to do a lot of cold calling we had to
really believe in what we were doing and
we had to be willing to like be willing
to take no for an answer and that's
really just I call it shyness but some
people are not willing to pick up the
phone and talk to someone I don't know
regardless of but if you know if you
really believe in what you're doing I
think that gives you sort of the added
confidence to just you know make those
kind of cold calls but your your comment
about risk I think that's a very
interesting thing and you're willing to
take on risk I have a friend who's been
extremely successful in the
merchandising business and he was trying
to convince me that I should be selling
more clothing through the fitness
centers and I had this discussion I said
oh man that just looks risky to me you
know how about merchandise their knees
to risk that's an opportunity I mean he
saw what I saw is very risky sa's up an
opportunity and I said you're the one
who had this huge risk I said you have
four kids and you continually you know
signed over the mortgage on your house
over and over again every time you open
the new store is that risk I never sign
at risk and you said you were the one
that's missing I said I never saw any
risk and to each of us in our own fields
we never saw risk and I think that if
you're on the right track you may not
know how to get there but if you know
where you going my father used to say
you don't know where you're going any
road will get you there once you know
where you're going you know you'll get
there and the risk you know I just
didn't see the risk he didn't see the
risk in his field and I've talked to a
lot of entrepreneurs and they feel the
same way if they if they believe in the
idea they'll get there and this idea of
you have to be a risk taker I
certainly don't consider myself at this
table what I would say to that though is
getting comfortable with failure or
potential failure you know I think on
some level just even sitting in this
room having gotten into Stanford
Business School you know you guys are a
successful group of people you know it's
like I'm sure you've had you know like
all of us we've had failure but you know
I know going in you know graduating from
business school you know I had gotten
with jobs i wanted to get and I had you
know gone to you know I got into
business school and I was all excited
and you know basically the things that I
had done professionally I had done in
part because you know I was going to the
you know is considered successful
starting a company it you know you get
hung up on you know they are like who
are you it is not one of the things that
it's like when you tell your friends and
especially a 2000 it very much was you
know everybody's going to be an
entrepreneur and when you talk to people
that went to business school like in the
late 80s it was like everyone's going
into real estate investment you know
it's like there's always sort of the
cool job to get out of business school
that everybody's sort of buying for BC
was you know it for a while especially
like when I was in school